*Musica*
"Dovrebbero morire tutti", ah tranquilli ne muoiono
un sacco... non perche stiano male eh
O per chissa quale incidente, moriamo perche ci ammazzate, o ci spingete a farlo... il motivo?
"Frocio di merda", "scherzo della natura", "non sei una vera donna", "fai schifo", "ma non ti vergogni?", "meriti la morte"
Ogni volta che una persona omosessuale o bisessuale o trans perde la vita c'è sempre qualcuno che commenta con frasi tipo "finalmente", "se l'è meritato", "uno in meno"
Come si fa ad essere felici per la morte di qualcuno... come cazzo fate...
A volte vorrei essere anch'io cosi sprezzante, però la morte l'ho vissuta in prima persona non ci riesco
Le invidio davvero le persone che riescono a commentare la morte altrui con così tanta leggerezza
Perche se lo fai.. vuol dire che non hai mai perso nessuno
"è una malattia andrebbero rinchiusi nei manicomi come facevano un tempo"
Ah beh si se per questo un tempo bruciavano anche le streghe, praticavano dei salassi per abbassare la febbre e utilizzavano interiora di rane e rospi per distillare pozioni d'amore.. wow..
Benvenuti nel 2021 però ragazzi oggi le malattie sono altre, sono il cancro, l'alzheimer, il diabete, l'elenco è lunghissimo e colpiscono tutto
Cuore, polmoni, sangue, mente, per ogni centimetro del corpo che riuscite ad immaginare esiste una malattia che lo distrugge
Le malattie sono orribili.. non permettono alle persone di vivere la propria vita anzi la peggiorano, la rovinano, in alcuni casi la tolgono
Alle persone di vivere la propria vita anzi la
peggiorano la rovinano in alcuni casi la tolgono
Io la mia vita potrei viverla tranquillamente
eppure forse sono malato, forse hanno ragione loro
Ma la mia malattia è l'odio degli altri,
la mia malattia potresti essere tu
"Non capisco cosa ci sia da da essere tanto orgogliosi, tutto questo ostentare è ridicolo e non necessario"
Spesso ci viene detto, intimato in posto di nasconderci, di non vivere la nostra vita serenamente,
Però più delle volte le motivazioni che ci vengono date sono un pochino da stronzi
"Mi fa schifo"
Guarda da un'altra parte..
"Ma non ti vergogni ?"
Si..per te...
"Che bisogno c'è di ostentare ?"
Non ho mai visto due sposi uscire da una chiesa di nascosto
"E ai bambini chi ci pensa?, cosa dirò a mio figlio?"
Se non riesci a parlare con tuo figlio il problema è tuo, e poi se non riesci a spiegare una cosa semplice come l'amore a tuo figlio
Cosa farai quando dovrai parlargli di odio, se ti mette cosi tanta ansia parlargli di diversità, come farai nel momento in cui dovrai spiegargli
Che ci sono bambini che muoiono di fame, per via della guerra..ci sono bambini che vengono amati da piccoli e odiati da grandi
*Corda tesa*
"Diciamolo chiaramente! l'omosessualità è contro natura perché contraddice la legge naturale della vita, la differenza tra sessi e la riproduzione della specie"
Fatemi capire una cosa tutti quanti voi che credete in questa tesi del contro natura come se fosse una motivazione, esistono uomini che asportano organi
Da cadaveri per inserirli dentro altre persone e permettere loro di vivere, esistono pratiche che consentono ai neonati di uscire dalla pancia di una donna
Senza passare dal buco che la natura ha predisposto per il parto, esistono persone che vivono grazie a dei macchinari, chi espleta da un fianco
Chi respira da una bombola, chi si alimenta dal naso, perché quando questo succede ve ne state zitti, perché li chiamiamo natura o progresso
Quando fanno comodo a noi, perché diventano atti abominevoli e contro natura quando permettono ad una persona di ottenere non solo
Un corpo nel quale si riconoscano ma l'unico corpo nel quale riesca a vivere con maggiore serenità questa esistenza
"Non capisco; ma quindi devo darti del maschio o della femmina?"
Una domanda.. non capisci o non vuoi capire? perché in quel caso fatti i c***i tuoi, se invece ci tieni a capire estrapola dal contesto
Ascolta con quali aggettivi si definisce una persona, che pronomi usa, pensa che ad alcuni puoi anche chiedere..
Oscar wilde diceva.. a volte è meglio tacere e sembrare stupidi che aprire bocca e togliere ogni dubbio, è cosi difficile accettare
Che non potete capire tutto al primo colpo
"Non ci si deve preoccupare per gli ammalati di AIDS perché tanto è una perdita di tempo
l'AIDS è una punizione di dio e gli ammalati sono i soli responsabili della loro infezione"
Queste sono le parole di una donna mentre andava in chiesa, più di un milione di bambini dai 0 ai 9 anni sono positivi al virus dell'HIV
Dio vuole forse la morte dei bambini? cosa fa paura dell'HIV e dell'AIDS? il modo in cui viene contratto?
35 milioni di persone sono morte quindi perché dio punisce il sesso non protetto gay o etero che sia? seguendo questo ragionamento dio ha ucciso
Tra le 70 e le 200 milioni di persone attraverso la peste nera per punire il semplice fatto che respirassero..
"I gay sono bestie senz'anima e meritano di essere discriminati e insultati"
Questo veniva detto durante un family day
"L'omosessualità è peccato"
Questo veniva detto invece nel vecchio testamento e nello stesso paragrafo qualche riga sopra viene descritto come atto abominevole per dio nutrirsi di crostacei
E dio ce la doveva proprio avere con chiunque ingurgitasse pesce eh.. la masturbazione è peccato.. il divorzio è peccato.. dire bugie è peccato
Eppure improvvisamente quando si tratta di rompere il c***o su queste faccende stiamo tutti zitti..se credete davvero che la morte di una persona che ha semplicemente
Un gusto diverso dal vostro sia una cosa gradita a dio vorrei vedervi fare quello che ha fatto l'ISIS, buttando dai palazzi delle persone sospettate di omosessualità
Con dei cappucci in testa, se per te è normale vai dalla tu la spinta..
Non importa come vivrai, le scelte che prenderai e i motivi che darai, chi vuole odiarti lo farà sempre e comunque, non puoi parlare con chi non ha orecchie
Non puoi far ragionare chi non ha un cervello, non puoi emozionare chi non ha un cuore, una cosa però puoi farla
Smettere di sentirti in colpa per ciò che sei, per ciò che desideri, per ciò che provi
Se loro non si vergognano di odiare perché tu dovresti vergognarti ad amare